hi everybody welcome back to the bear
trap podcast this is actually a special
feature with the creator of gex spot uh
I did a prior video in which I actually
took a deep dive uh watching this tool
live and talking about why it makes
sense to be using it uh and all of that
background but today I thought it made a
lot of sense to just bring Jess on uh
ask him about how and why he made this
thing and maybe go through uh a day of
looking at it just so that we can get it
through his eyes um so yeah welcome on
the podcast Jess thanks for yeah thanks
for having me yeah it's always it's
always great to talk about gex with you
um and I'm happy to share this tool with
you guys yeah um so honestly my first
question is um why and how the hell did
you make this
thing that's a good question uh I
actually got started looking at spot G
levels um so they do a newsletter and
they put out these gamma levels uh
pre-market and I would mark them on my
chart and so I was I primarily trade uh
Futures es and there's a strong
correlation well direct correlation
between es and SPX options um so their
levels were great for um looking for
those local reversions right and then
for a time I kind of wondered what it
would look like uh because there those
levels are based off of Open interest
and then you know if you go a few hours
even after initial balance a lot of that
data has become old technically um so I
I wanted to see what the gamma looked
like in tr
day and uh that's kind of how gex spot
started uh I would just basically just
plot a snapshot of the gamma structure
and then um the way I would have it real
time refresh was I I would save the
image in the same spot uh over and over
and over and then I'll just use that as
my reference uh while trading um and
then it kind of grew from there I
started sharing on my
Discord um or on Note chord and then
someone suggested I posted on Twitter so
I started doing that and then uh yeah it
kind of turned into a whole thing uh we
have a website now where it's actually
real time yeah this is the that's the
website that I'm on for everybody and
then I ALS Al we're going to look at the
Twitter as well uh and then compare it
to SPX over the course of this video so
that we can kind of look at all the
different aspects of the tool um yeah
yeah yeah I and it's been it's been a
trip seeing it like real time versus the
static images before um even with like
saving the images as quickly as I could
um there's just something very different
about watching it change real time on on
the website that um it's hard to explain
there there's an intuitive sense to
gamma um that I mean I haven't been
trading it for very long but I know
other people have been trading for years
and they say there's a there's a feeling
to it that you get um that's hard to
articulate but it it comes naturally
just due to the the way that it works
and the way that it interacts with like
spot price well it's it's it's flow
right it's the same thing that right
because you were telling me that you
trade a lot using a footprint and so you
see these like massive orders hitting
the tape or those of you that have
watched bookmap um you see liquidity
moving live is is that fair to say yeah
you it's like you can feel like the
heartbeat out through the tape uh
through through footprint um and you
know you can see the the battle between
uh buyers and sellers going on and it's
very similar to how uh watching spot
price approach some larg gamma node uh
it'll react to it and the gamma node
itself will also react in kind um it's a
very close
relationship yeah and it's it's it's
honestly amazing how well this works and
I can say this and in this video because
you know I was watching uh there'll be
an example later in the video I was
watching this yesterday and and there
was a really really clear instance
although we're not doing it live because
we're recording on a um on Easter
actually um so uh but but I'll do in in
the first video if you guys want to
refer to that not only does it cover the
you know why all this stuff works but
also I'm going to be using um or I use
the live ver version of gex spot uh but
what I wanted to say more broadly is
that uh like you were saying because
we're just taking this is just open
interest and volume you would think that
because the volume nodes are just a mix
of to open to close to buy to sell we
don't really know um that it wouldn't be
as informative as it is but the fact is
that because um or at least this is this
is my way of reading it you can correct
me if I'm wrong you've been watching it
longer than I have but but because
underlying price is moving in tandem
with the that volume coming into those
strikes over time you actually develop a
pretty intuitive sense of um is are
there more contracts being added here or
are the contracts being taken away
um yeah it's it's actually very similar
to in order flow when you
see
um so the classic term is is absorption
so there
you know you'll reach some level and you
get a sense of um a whole bunch of
orders hitting the offer at a very
specific level and you can see how it's
someone large that's taking it in
they're they're offering liquidity and
they're eating it all up from all of the
smaller orders and you know technically
each of these you know for every buy
there's a sell and for every sell
there's a buy um so it's not necessarily
that you're
classifying uh the difference between
whether it is or buy or sell but rather
there's this level at which there's so
much activity going on it becomes a
pivot and it's a pivot that price will
react to so you in classic terms of uh
resistance right so buyers trying to buy
into resistance either they break
through and you get a breakout you get
the retest and continuation or you get
buyer exhaustion it fails and you know
the pivot becomes the top and it's very
similar to how um spot price will move
into these gamma nodes where okay maybe
people are buying calls maybe it's maybe
it's paper buying calls maybe it's
dealer selling calls um but it's it
doesn't really matter although that
sounds kind of handwavy um it's just the
fact that you know this is such a large
uh Hive of activity that um we either
break through and we retest and we don't
fall below it or we fail and it becomes
the top for the day or for whatever time
frame no I I think I think that that's a
great way to put it because at the end
of the day right like this is a tool
that's made for the practice of trading
inaday so understanding how to how to
use it right having a Shand for reading
it is likely more relevant than knowing
all of the background although to be
honest I you know the background is my
favorite part yeah um yeah but um the
other thing I wanted to add and and I
think I think you you were kind of
mentioning this right like it
it these levels are how would I put it
they're mushy in a way right because um
viscous V
viscous that's a good way to put it too
right because because if you think about
it in terms of hedging obligations and
and this goes a little bit into the why
right but it's not it's not a binary
level right it's not as if under a level
um uh all of a sudden nothing's
happening and then above that level
everything's happening it's more like as
we move into and away from it um there
is a gradual transition and hedging
obligations and activity at that level
um and so in the same way as perhaps a
volume profile or something like that I
see what you're saying about about
viscosity as we're heading into a very
high volume area it becomes more
difficult for price to move whereas if
we're moving through a lower volume area
price can just uh kind of snap through
all that uh what would you say uh lack
of liquidity or that those air pockets
so to speak right yeah no one wants to
transact there and that's long area yeah
exactly um yeah I think that's a really
good way to put it
um so um yeah I'm actually going to move
forward a little bit and and again for
this video we're kind of assuming that
everybody has a a pretty decent
understanding of all of the colors and
stuff in this tool of course um it is
kind of nice you can hop over here
change the colors yourself I'm just
using the defaults so you know if you're
watching this at home you want to know
what we're talking about maybe set
everything to the default just so that
you could have a pretty simple reference
but um uh yeah um one thing I did want
to ask you about and you know I'll have
clarified this in the other video but
just to remind everybody um these dots
uh what are they how do you use
them right right so uh so gex spot is
it's done in in price letter form right
so we're just looking at our prices in
our for our vertical axis and then our x
axis is the the gex or the
exposure um and so it's great for the
you know actively trading getting the
sense of where we are in relation to our
levels um but the trade-off is that
there's no access for time uh so at
every moment you're really seeing just
the current state of the gex structure
um and so in order to make up for this
we have the dots uh which are just a way
of showing the prior state so um for the
the default colors the white dots I
believe uh for the one minutes um that's
where the gex for that level was and
then uh for the 5 10 15
30 uh that was those are all the
previous States at those dots and uh in
a sense that's how you get the feeling
of progression
or or in the case of like a classic um
uh put squeeze or or or short squeeze at
the end of day where you see all the
gamma evaporating from all the put gamma
uh below spot um you'll see the the
change or the difference between the
dots and and the current
states yeah that that makes a lot of
sense and it also kind of points to the
fact that
right the tool is built I think like in
a way that it looks really simple at the
same time though watching it during all
these different types of days whether
you have a chop day or a trend day or a
um you need that screen time right
because uh and this is just something
that I've noticed myself from using it
right we're going to look at one day
which was a trend day which was
yesterday um Thursday April 6th um and
you know the gex spot behaved in very
specific way uh and so you kind of have
to build up your sense it's like with
using any any tool right any tool that
you're familiar with it takes a little
bit of craftsmanship a little bit of um
familiarity
um yeah a little bit of discretion um it
it
definitely there is's you know I love
using the term viscous and then there's
like the other other analogy I like of
you know it's it's sort of like um like
driving a car where gamma is the rate of
applying brakes or gas um but there's
there's a lot of physical analogies that
correspond to how the tool works and and
looks um that yeah it it does come with
screen time and it's hard to
uh necessarily
verbalize uh uh I don't know if this
really is a good well well a little bit
I mean no it's it's it is relevant for
today because um and again this is just
mostly in reference to uh the first
video but just as a reminder right
because uh gamma is a derivative right
it's about acceleration um if we see a
big gamma level break whether to the
upside or the downside we expect to see
uh a moment of acceleration on the other
side of it uh in the same way as we're
just talking about air pockets uh or uh
places where people not don't want to
transact and price how price moves
really quickly through them the same can
be said for this type of a distribution
um so uh yeah in any case let's let's
move on um to Friday and then maybe I
can sort of like rack your brain as to
how you would read all these different
cases I'm just going to start with this
image and this is just gek spot off the
open um this is posted at 9:31 in the
morning and this is basically purely
well actually I'll leave it to you what
are you looking at here how would you
analyze it what's the first thing that
you think when you see this
well the first thing I I'm thinking is
that the most
obvious um strike or I I like to call
North Stars is 4100 above us and I'm
also looking at the call gex at uh 4075
to see if we auction down towards that
if if we can hold above that um and then
mostly I'm watching the major gamas and
seeing where they're pointing out um
large strikes of interest because those
typically form uh places where people
are expecting us to go whether that's
informed Traders or just the market as a
whole um those typically form targets
for me in terms of uh if I'm looking for
a trend day or if I'm looking for a
balance day you know these are my lines
in the sand so to speak okay so are you
when you say the major levels you're
talking about major negative gamma at 4
40 and major positive gamma at 41 19
probably
4120 yes yes
exactly and then and then those are kind
of like defining the intraday range for
you was that fair to
say yeah so in as you're saying before
there's like a look for balance days
there's a look for Trend days um balance
days it sounds really simple but
typically we just auction between our
major gamma levels so these are you know
the points at which um people are
expecting a reversion or people are not
expecting us to go beyond or I'm not
expecting us to go beyond um so I'll be
looking for reversions at those levels
with zero gamma typically forming the
pivot in
between very similar to how you know a
VPO or volume put of control will
develop and there will be some value
area high value area low and we're
looking for auction between or within
this range right yeah now for the other
kind of day for Trend days
um typically gex spot will just have
that look to it where it's just skewed
and you know on those days major gamma
in the direction that we're trending is
is my North Star that's where I'm
looking for us to go and I'm looking for
us to maintain uh spot above or below or
on that side of zero gamma so zero gamma
is kind of forming the L and sand behind
us for Trend to continue yeah and you
know and I'd love to get you on at some
point also you know and we can
distinguish make it maybe make a video
trying to distinguish between these
different types of days right because
today we're looking at a day that was
arguably um a range day with a little
bit of trend spiciness added to it uh
but quite choppy action um but uh yeah I
there was one other thing I actually
wanted to mention which is at at least
for me when I was looking at this
yesterday because I was also trading
yesterday um my immediate reaction when
I saw that spot price was at 481 and
that all these people were in these
calls from yes from the day before uh
from Wednesday was oh man the Market's
going to open and they're going to be
off sides on your calls in other words
they probably bought them at a better
price and now uh they're going to be
losing money so there's going to be this
sort of instant desire to liquidate some
of these guys which to my mind meant um
it's very likely that price is actually
going to move a little lower before it
starts to move higher
um does that make make sense to you do
you do you look at that as well or is
that more of a niche thing no I think
that that makes a lot of sense yeah
that's absolutely fair to say um I you
know looking at es2 there was that drive
um to auction lower you know we could
see shorts kind of piling into um I
believe it was like 4100 is yeah 4100
490 you're talking es levels now on ES
yeah looking looking for that break
sorry 498
yeah okay cool yeah let me move on to uh
the next image later in the day um which
is so we were April 6 9:31 move on to
the next one these are every 15 minutes
right because this will be okay yeah
this is 9:46 a.m. on that day okay and I
can see that some some volume has come
in but but not not a ton
um and and maybe maybe just makes sense
to be highlighting the 4050 here a
little bit seeing a little volume come
in there not super surprising cuz all
you will say by 946 just looking at the
price action again open there
liquidation of the calls come right down
by 946 we're all the way down here um so
you correspondingly
see um that sorry let me get back on the
Twitter that they added volume to these
40 50s um Let me let me move uh forward
a little bit um so that we can see what
happened next this is going to
uh 10:15 a.m. okay what are you thinking
here at this point I'm thinking there
going to be a balance day um just from
so like looking at Price action
um us coming down we're kind of hitting
this reversion at I think it was 4098 we
auction up and then the way how the way
that g spot looks is typical of a
balance day currently you know we're
hover round zero gamma it's fairly even
on either side um in terms of how far
the gex is you know there's 4050 puts
that are looking to maybe monetize or
maybe they're they're selling them and
then the 4100 calls is the other end of
the range um so I'm expecting us
to essentially range obviously that's a
pretty large range um to bounce between
but that's how I'm reading it currently
do you do you make anything of the fact
that the 4100s seem to be more dominant
at this stage than the than the put side
yeah actually so so with our Max change
gex by strike is a mouthful um on the
bottom right uh you know that that also
tells me that um so to explain what it
is it's just saying that for each of
those time frames this is the strike
that underwent the greatest change in
gex
and then it tells you the notional
amount um when it looks like this I'm
you know that's actually a bias towards
us leaning towards uh
4100 um so
if the the very simple way of looking at
it is that you know if every time frame
is looking at a very particular strike
and they're all increasing then it's
pretty likely that this is where most of
the interest uh lies and this is the
option wants to go and then another
thing that I'd add in terms of the why
for that um right you could say well
okay Jess why are they not just selling
a ton of those 4100s and and my answer
to that would be it's actually pretty
simple it's
um that if you were selling options
you'd actually want to spread out a
little bit more than that right that
would be an insane amount of
concentrated risk uh whereas if you're
buying options and you want the point of
Maximum convexity Because You're expect
expecting a specific move you actually
want to Pile in exactly where everybody
else is um that's a little bit more of a
uh how would I put it more of a
technical why type of Point well I think
it's also that you know this is at 10 in
the morning right like this is so early
that it also doesn't make sense to be
shorting like that out of the money um
you know usually you want the the day to
kind of develop more before you start
shorting um unless you're shorting way
further out Wings
right 4100 at this time would be kind of
ill advised that that's a really that's
a that's a a much better way to put it
because also what I was saying actually
it flips into the end of the day right
at that point if you're selling uh
implied Vol you actually do want to be
selling the strikes that everybody else
is in because of the pinning uh
potential but um exactly at this early
in the day it's a a little weird to to
if those if those are predominantly
sells okay so I'm going to just hop over
the price chart here so we can see where
we were trading again this is um the
time stamp down here 10:14 we look at
10:14 here on trading view um we were
looking at right here so we could see
that there was a like off that low there
at 4070 made a pretty big move here 1014
is here um so then the question would be
as we start to come down here right um
into the next time stamp which I'm
guessing is going to be uh 1030 which is
going to be right here are they getting
out of those 4100s or do they continue
to add add to them right
um at least that's what I was looking
for because I actually traded this
yesterday
um let's let's see here um Okay cool so
this is 10:30 perfect um and uh you can
actually this is exactly this is a
moment where we can use the dots where
we can see well you know um did volume
increase what did it do versus prior
volume and um it's the same right like
all the dots are all here still
um yeah my bias is
still at this point it's still balanced
right because we're kind of we we came
back down right we we failed the sell
off below now we auction higher we
failed the break uh on ES we failed to
break
4111 um so now I'm thinking well we're
probably just to do a range
day you know range around zero gamma
essentially yeah around this uh zero
is it's the okay right under 480 over
here I got you all right let's move on
to the next one at
uh uh 10:45 and I'll I'll skip through
faster later on but
umh yeah in any case uh this is yeah
10:45 okay anything different
here
that's a trick question it's a trick
question I see something really yeah
what do you see the 40
90s oh
yeah cash I didn't even see that yeah
right because look at the the dots on
the 490s uh even though the 4100 stayed
exactly the same which is actually in of
itself the 4100 started to add wow even
though we auction lower there that's
like
a wow that's a very good cash thanks
man no yeah that's
like yeah so because we're looking for
that that's like that that point where
okay are we going to make a higher low
or are we going to continue downtrend
but clearly someone or large number of
people or probably into 4090 calls
because typically you know when you see
spot price moving down um there's still
a there's a Mone relationship with like
uh gamma right so like if you're moving
away from a strike the gamma will
naturally decrease because it's only
highest for at the money contracts um
but in this case if you have enough
people piling into those calls even as
spot price is uh auctioning lower
clearly there there's a very large drive
towards
um those Deltas wow yeah that's that's a
really really good point and it's
something that you know I just want to
emphasize it's that um uh and I'll pull
this up because I pulled this up before
or actually no this will be um I'll
leave I'll leave everybody to go to the
previous video in order to see this but
um that's it's really important to say
that gamma is the highest for at the
money options so uh I'm just rering what
you said but if spot price moves down
then naturally all the gamma exposure of
the lower strikes is going to be
accentuated um even if the volume on
those or the open interest on those
stays exactly the same so the fact that
here the spot price came down thereby
accentuating the overall uh the the the
uh extent of the bars on the put side
and yet the 490s still gained means that
there was some serious serious volume
hitting the 490s not to mention that the
4100s um aside from this one 10-minute
prior dot stayed relatively consistent
um over that time
period um and I think that's something
we should add to our gex vot I need to
think about how to add that but that
that's actually a really good
um point there any yeah no I mean always
uh you have to you have to be paying
attention um it's a yeah it's not it's
not a it's not a tool for for for for
for the lazy um no it's not
um all right cool so uh we see this we
get a little skeptical we like oh okay
you know um and what was this
10:45 um I'm just going to hop back over
to price again uh all right
10:45 was right here um and then yeah it
was a very significant low and then 11
a.m. um and this is the last one I'll
I'll I'll get into before we actually
get into the actual sort of more
trending stuff but uh this is at 11:00
a.m. and I think this was probably the
most revealing of the entire day to be
honest uh because price was still at 476
and you can see not only were the 490s
still around where we saw them last time
but the
4100s despite the fact that spot is so
far away and has been away for a while
look at where they are they're all
they're right
back yeah just blowing up in
interest volume
yeah um yeah that's why that's what I
wanted to do today as as the video for
today because I just thought like yeah
it's a pretty good
example yeah yeah um okay so I'm GNA
actually take this chart and put it um
get it just to be half the screen over
here and then we'll have this guy be the
other half um so that now we can start
to see everything together
um beautiful okay um
so this is where we're looking at and
let's switch over here to a five minute
so we have
that
great sorry guys okay here we go um
expand this access a little bit
beautiful okay so now we're looking at
um 11 which was right here um right
before we got this big pump and
um hold on one sec yeah uh are you
trying to show the the website uh chart
oh I see it switched all oh I got I can
only see the uh yeah the static okay
well yeah I guess I'll cut that out then
um in any case okay let's let's keep
going then um okay so uh looking at the
price chart now we're looking at uh
11:00 a.m. and so you see this pump
starting to happen a stupid stupid
question but where do you think it's
going to
go well it's it's it's the simplest
answer every time right like now I'm
thinking okay well I'm just looking to
go to Major gamma um which is 4100
that's where everyone wants to go that's
probably where we're going to head up as
simple as that sounds all right so so
buy the hell out of it close your eyes
and then just
uh basically
just walk away okay cool um all right
now let's you know you guys know what
the next couple hours are it's just you
know rally so then let's look at the
progression on gex spot as that happens
um so we had this and then fast forward
15 minutes later yeah
jeez and we haven't spot hasn't even
moved that much we're only at 4083
here 11:14 my
God so you had you had time to get in if
you wanted to play the move up to
4100 yeah it was definitely this was
probably
your even though not technically your
last chance but the easiest chance to
enter for a breakout um just because I
know that that that Trend up towards
4100 was still a pretty hard uh Trend to
enter at least for you know trading Es
at least it was a really grindy Trend
despite like that clear interest towards
that
level yeah and from I mean from an
options Trader perspective um well
actually that's a longer video but yeah
if you want to trade this with zero DTE
options or something like that um
essentially
you um you know you take some naked you
enter you do ghetto surprises right you
enter into some naked calls to ride the
initial move then you sell some calls
against it once you think that you know
we'll be petering out if you think the
trend's going to continue and we're
going to go to 4100 in fact you probably
sell the 4100s let's be honest um yeah
and uh yeah also notable that Max change
every single one except for the 10minute
is uh is the 4100 strike that's kind of
fun yeah well it's also the 10-minute is
the 4050 puts dime right their their gex
is increasing that's really the the put
value um evaporating as that's a really
good point and that's what's adding fuel
to the fire to get us to actually uh
squeeze squeeze
all right fast forward um okay we can
skip that very intense very
intense uh tell me if you want me to
stop I I don't know you know just okay
let's let's let's stop around here this
seems this seems nice what time was this
12:44 no let's do more let's look at the
uh 130 um
yeah uh is this 130 no next one here we
go
okay so we all know or most of us know
anyway 130 important sort of pivot time
for the market same as like same as like
12:30 for whatever reason um not not
really what we're discussing here but
okay what do you think of now Jess now
that you're seeing
this well so one side effect of like
when we do hit major gamma
is usually if if it's if there's such a
clear interest very early on before
we're even closer right you're thinking
or I'm thinking that um there's so many
called buyers most likely who are
looking for the pump towards that level
um if they were doing it early on
usually that means that when we do get
there people are going to start taking
profits um and if there was so much
interest uh early on when spot was
nowhere near it then it becomes very
very difficult as we approach it um to
then exceed it because then you get this
sort of Mucky effect of you know it's
like it's like a magnet right where we
try to get over it then people you know
they out of money calls finally hit in
the money so they liquidate those and
then we get you know pulled back down
and then we sort of bounce between the
two um but at the same time you know due
to that that Trend up um it's highly
unlikely
at least in the underlying right if if
if you were trying to short on the way
up um there's probably a shorts who were
trapped and so they're trying to cover
every time price comes back down and so
you just get this bounding effect around
these major Jamma levels um yeah yeah
you kind of I was I was also about to
say right it's we're just in the muck
now right if you think about it
according to our prior analogies of the
volume profile um it's you know there's
just so much transacted here each one of
these different strikes I'm pointing at
the screen now even though nobody can
see me um each each one of them has its
own sort of magnetic effect right it's
like it pushes us up from if it's
underneath spot pushes us down if it's
above spot as it's decaying and so this
whole thing it's like a giant magnetic
field where um all the interactions are
a little messed up and Mucky
um anyway that's that's that's how I see
it pinning effects yeah pinning effects
um all right so at this point in the day
the thinking was all right might as well
go make another coffee go do something
else read a book be done for the
day something like
that what's the point anymore um yeah
let's you know moving forward same same
same um you know what I'm just going to
skip to the end of the day here uh we
did technically there was a small move
here like towards over here um uh it was
this was a 300 p.m move um yeah it's was
like 34 35 on there was a popup and then
I believe someone was offering
there yeah I mean they tried to uh right
the 4105 ended up being the real center
of our distribution so to speak and they
tried to pop it up to
4107 uh this is SPX obviously and uh
that that did not in accordance with our
theory of mod that that was not well
received
mhm um yeah CU because we were mostly
around this 4100 node this was the most
powerful one and then 4105 was sort of
the next one so you think about it as
like if you were to split the muck in
half right literally halfway through the
mck is
um so you know back of the envelope
Trader math right there
but yeah works all right
uh last slide end of day uh what do we
what are you thinking
here well I'm thinking that there's
clearly there's no more breakout or
there's very unlikely you know this is
at the point where you know if you were
long and you didn't take profit I mean
obviously if if you're in options
hopefully you you already did if you
were on the E mini it's probably time to
just close it and not bother you know
looking for more and it's unlikely that
we would you know try to short for like
a waterfall break
was possibly on the table um because the
trend up wasn't like a very like we said
earlier it wasn't like a normal Trend
day right where you have a
clear flows that are that are pushing uh
price it was very grindy and so usually
that's indicative of know if we're able
to break uh some prior pivot then you
can get these waterfall effects um but
you know at this point about 1550
minutes before it close it's not quite
as likely without some serious um
activity or serious selling activity
going
on so if you like let's say right
because we're not um we're not
necessarily interested in looking at the
day in retrospective and being like Oh I
would have traded it like this or I
would have done that although you know
to some extent we you know we have to do
that in order to kind of explain the
Tool uh but uh sort of in light of that
what would you have needed to see in
order to have traded for a waterfall
break to the
downside I would it sounds I don't know
how to put
it it's it's fair to say wouldn't do it
you know like you think there's no way
there's no
way yeah it would have to like I would
have to be watching it happen and then
by some I would unlikely be you know if
unless some I short at the top or
something and then like was like doing
some trailing stop business but I I
don't really like those in the first
place anyway um but no no I I don't
think that
uh
sorry I lost my train thought no no
that's fine I mean to be honest I agree
with you because uh it would be one
thing if we hit this point in G in in in
in Gag spot and it was still 2 p.m.
right if it's still 2 p.m. hey all those
guys in calls there's a ton of stuff to
get liquidated um up top right and then
if we break underneath the 4100 ooh
they're kind of in trouble because
they're on the wrong side of theta um
but but it's it's 3:45 there's 15
minutes left in the day and we're at
um so it's it's a bit of a different
situation yeah yeah then the then the
odds are sort of increasing that you
know as we're stuck here we're just
going to remain stuck here unless
something some outside force comes in
but at this point yeah it's it's too
late really for some some other
cascading effects to come into play all
right awesome yeah and then you know
just this is the last a little bit of
Market stuff but all right we bounced
back up off surprise surprise just
underneath 4100 497 on SPX boom bounced
right up close at
4105 which was um obviously and this is
now I'm on the website again because the
website is showing you know the last uh
gamma from and you can also do all this
fun zooming stuff and all this stuff but
in any case you can see how insane the
Gam exposure was for 4105 at the close
and the reason for that is 415s are the
closest to the money um and so the
effect uh and and this with this we get
into a different video which maybe will
be made eventually with regards to
pinning and pin slippage and all those
things which is kind of fun but uh no
surprise that we pinned here at 4105 on
the dot for the close
[Music]
um yeah it's too much much too too too
too uh too intense a a statement or fine
no no yeah it's it's they're like uh
they're like pools of of magnet
magnetism right like spot price gets
sucked to them or it gets repelled
away those EOD effects are are pretty
pretty crazy though yeah I feel like
people should just get you know if they
if just just for the joy of watching
that is uh it's it's nice yeah
um in any case uh that kind of concludes
our analysis or like uh mini analysis of
a day and we still have like five
minutes left so I kind of wanted to ask
you right for users of the tool whether
they're users of the free part or the or
the or the paid tool um what type of
stuff are you guys looking to to keep
building like what do you see in the
future for the tool um yeah what's
what's what's coming up yeah
so our most shortterm feature goal right
now is to add a pure zero DTE
filter um you know right now we are
including all expiries in our in our bot
and you know with gamma due to how it
falls off for later expiries this you
know still kind of giving you mostly the
same sense as if it was just a pure zero
tte um but I think and this is something
that that you've kind of taught me um
looking at current day expirations of
gex can often help uh kind of determine
whether if it's likely we're getting a
trend day right so if there's like put
gex below us for the current day expiry
then you know maybe I'll look for that
um so that's one feature we want to do
and then beyond that we're working on uh
we're about done with our CR charts
integration so people can plot our
levels directly to their charts and then
after that I'll be doing our motive wave
integration uh but in general we want to
have a way for users to directly plot
the levels um to their platform whether
that's you know s charts motive wave
maybe ninja Trader um just because that
added you know one of the biggest
bonuses of a tool at least the live
version is that
um you know you're abstracting this data
into this easily interpretable way and
every little you know even if it's
marginal every little increment towards
making it easier to understand it and
like you know whether that's being able
to scale it or putting it directly on
the chart that you're using to execute
you know these all make these little
differences um so they those are usually
our goals for our features um and then
in the medium term or long term you know
we do want to add more
tickers um the indexes like the cues
um so people can trade off those um and
that's mostly it at least that's that's
kind of on our our current road map well
I mean that's that's already kind of a
lot to to be honest a lot yeah yeah yeah
yeah but it's it's good it's good um
it's fun to make these for people I
think um yeah it's fun it's fun to use
them too um and I look forward to uh you
know I do want to have spy on there at
some point I'll be pushing for a couple
different
things we're getting to it yeah yeah all
right the man's busy leave him
alone uh yeah no thanks thanks for
coming on this is like uh this is
actually a perfect time to wrap up and I
think you know hopefully this will help
a lot of people understand uh how to use
it how you see it um obviously how you
see it it's not necessarily the only way
to use it but I think it's always nice
to um have a sense for what the intended
purpose was kind of and then you know we
can all feel free to misuse it as much
as we want right yeah abuse
it um yeah thank you for having me on
it's it's been
great